çok şükür ediyorum beni davet ettiğiniz
böyle biraz karanlık oldu ama kusura
bakmayın Ben de böyle başka bir yoga
kampı gibi birşey deyim hep böyle burada
kaçırmaya çalışıyorum falan filan
dolayısıyla böyle bu çok belki formayı
değil ama o da farklı bakış açısı olsun
size Evet davetiniz için Tekrardan
teşekkür ediyorum Şimdi şöyle bir
arkanızda bir deniz var Burası böyle
durgun biliriz çok sakin keyifle yüzü
resmi Deniz fakat sizden böyle çok
dalgalı yönünüzü bulamadığınız Bir
denizde bir denizci olarak yol
aldığınızı Hayal etmenizi istedim eve
Neyse ki Yanınızda bir dostunuz var
hayatınızı anlatan Aslında size yardımcı
olacak Size kendinizi yara Kendini Kendi
yarattığınız bir kuru soğanımız var Hadi
size şöyle bir geçmişe doğru gidelim eve
Evet bu da ben kendi pusulamı nasıl icat
etti mi yolda giderken neler keşfettiği
mi anlatacağım 30 Temmuz 1979'da bir
aslan burcu olarak doğdum Ben
Çocukluğumda ve böyle gençlik döneminde
aslında işte fikirlerini Belki de var
olduğunu bilmiyorum pek inanmıyordu
Belki çok da sorulmadı bir çocukluk ve
gençlik geçirdim ben bir aslan burcu
olarak olduğu düşünülen çok da kolay
olmasa gerek yok dramatik olarak bakmak
istemiyorum size bakmayın lütfen ama
hani böyle bir gerçeğin var hayatımda da
evveev kendi doğruları olan kendi de
kendi davranışlarını çocuğuna
benimsetmeye çalışan ilk babam vardı
kötü niyetli değil o da çocuklara
verdiği Hani o şekilde görmüş ve o
bildiği doğruları o tek doğrusu yönünde
ilerlemeye çalışan bir baba çocuğuna
Evet benimsetmeye çalışan çalışan bir
hayatım oldu dolayısıyla doğru var
bu doğru bildiğin yolda E bunu
benimsetmeye çalışıyor ev böyle değişik
bir çocukluk büyük işte gençlik yıllarım
devam ederken üniversite sınavı vakti
geldi ve ben sporculuğu bıraktım
herhangi bir Aslında böyle işleyip
işlemediğine çok da sorulmadı bana çünkü
şimdi Üniversitesi'ni Bu gerçeği vardı
bunu üniversiteye girmek zorundaydım ve
bir günde de böyle yüzücülük hayatım
yüzücü kariyerimi 12 yıllık profesyonel
kariyerine sonlandırdım şu Çünkü şöyle
bir doğru vardı o tek doğru dediğin şey
sporcu işte kız sporcu tek başına ayakta
kalamaz işte saygı görmez Ondan sonra
işte bu memlekette adam olamaz kazan
sağlayamaz gibi doğru var vardı bende
Dolayısıyla bu doğruları inandım ailem
de benim şekilde yönlendirmesiyle ve
spor bıraktım Ee hasbelkader işte
kazanıp işletme okudum çünkü o dönemde
içi çekme modaydı çevre
Evet arkadaşlar arkadaşlarım işte
işletme okuması gerek bu ve Bu
doğrultuda işte bir üniversiteyi
kazandım Hadi Başkent Üniversitesi'ni
kazandım orada okumaya devam ettim Fakat
o dönemde işte dört sene geçtikten sonra
ben yüzmeye Bırakmadan önce yüzme
hayatımda İyi de hiç borcudur milli
takımda falan yüzdüm Amerika'ya buluştu
gitme imkanım vardı fakat işte ailemden
çok sıcak bakmadı içine Kız başına işle
uğraştığını Hani Amerika'ya gidilir mi
düşüncesiyle böyle bir İçimde kalan
Belki bir ukte olduğundan bir nedir
bilmiyorum ama üniversiteyi bitirdikten
sonra Dilek çalışmak istemedim Evet
böyle Ne yapıp ne edip oyun tuşuna
gidecek önce köye gittim olmadı sonra ne
olunca gittim orada işte bastır yapmaya
namaz tüm yaptım pazarlama yönetimi
üzerine Master yaptım ve
ve yurt dışına böyle ayak basar basmaz
anlıyorsunuz size dayatılmış doğruların
Aslında tek doğru olmadığını farklı
çeşitli doğrular olduğunu Hatta Herkesin
kendi doğru doğrusu olabildiğini
görüyorsunuz ilk aydınlanma Yani benim
hayatımdaki yurtdışı seyahatinde olduğu
yurtdışında geçirdiğim zaman da oldum
bir kere böyle karar ver Senin kendi
karar verebilme mekanizmasını devreye
giriyor Ha o mekanizma arada yandı mı
Evet yandı böyle zıp zıp falan sesler
çıkıpta yanarken ama bir şekilde
doğruyoruz mu buldum işte Kendi
kararlarımı Aldım kendi sorunlarım vardı
artık ve bunun sonuçlarını kendim
katlanıyorum ve kendi mücadele ediyordum
Siz herhalde dediğin kulvara belki işte
heyecanlı geliyor zor ama heyecanlı
bilmiyorum ne düşünüyorsunuz Aynen öyle
acayip heyecanlı
de böyle dalgalı işte yeni bir değil
yeni bir kültür yeni arkadaşlar farklı
aile yapıları ve çok şanslıydım ki
kendim bu ters insanları aile yapılarını
kültürlerini yakından tanıma ve şarj
Onları yakın Ayrılamayız deneyimleme
şansı mı oldu farklı böyle bir ülkede
yaşadığını zaman anlıyorsunuz Aslında
tek bir bakış açısı olmadığını bildiğim
örnek vereyim işte gece böyle Mesela bir
defada çalışan bir arkadaşım vardı
arkadaş grubunda farklı sektörlerde İlla
böyle işte işletme okuyor orada
çalışıyor yukarıya yapmış gibi
arkadaşlarım ötesinde farklı farklı i
bisiklet tamircisi olan vardır gece
depoda çalışan vardı o insanlarla bir
arada birlikte muhabbet ediyor saatlerce
konuşabiliyor birlikte eğlene biliyorduk
ve onun dışında gördüm fark Başka bir
şey de çalışma hayatının üniversite
hayatından önce de başla ya bildiğiniz
gördüm ben yurt dışında
13 senenin sonunda ise yine çok da
aslında böyle en çok Tartışmaya açık bir
konu değil demiş Mahzen tamam mı biraz
çalıştıktan sonra de tekrar ülkeye
döndüm Çünkü bir baba ya Hadi gel işte
bir iş vardı ve o iş bir kız için
güvenli ve en risksiz işte ve o yolda
ilerlemek gerekiyordu ama artık benim de
doğrularım vardı ve işte Durgun bir
deniz de hani sakin risksiz Bir denizde
önümü rahat rahat göre göre gittiğin bir
yolda olmak yerine Aslında ben dalgalı
bir denize olmayı seçtim ev
Bu İstanbul'da da o dönem işte aramış
diyorum bir iş fırsatı buldum iyi bir
bankanın böyle pazarlama departmanında
çalışmaya başladım ailemi ikna etmem bir
şey saygıdeğer böyle bir iş olduğu için
onlar da çok fazla ses etmedi Ve
İstanbul Ankara'dan İstanbul'a tanıştık
taşındım iki aydınlanma yerindeki
anlatayım size başarı başarı sahip
olduğu özgüvenli ilişkili olduğunu
anladım Yani özgüvende nasıl oluşuyor
sahip olduğu bilgi ve nasıl onu anladım
ne demek istiyorum yani biri on
gösterebiliyor musun ya da mavi olan bir
şeyi o özgüvenle kırmızı olarak
karşındakine ikna edebiliyor musun
ve o da benim aslında böyle hayalin
olduğum hayalim olduğu inandığım işte
size belki okuyorsunuz okuduğunuzda
pazarlama kitaplarındaki o başarı
hikayelerinden birini ben de sahip olmak
istedim Fakat böyle Zaman geçtikçe
Aslında o başarı hikayelerini çok da
kendi açımdan çok mümkün olmadığını
biliyordum Hakikaten de böyle Geleceğe
dair kendinle ilgili o şekli ortaya
doğru çalıştığım yerde bir gelecek
göremiyorum bir o resmi Geleceğe dair
resmi çizemiyor dutu ikinci süper 3.
aydınlanma oldu 1 2 3 oldu tabi 3.
aydınlanma müziği sin istemedim
istediğimden çok ben ne istemediğim
bilerek yolunu buldum bilmiyorum belki
de doğru yetiştiremedim hani böyle
dediğim gibi çok gram ikram hiçbir şey
olsun istemiyorum ama bu Belki de ben
öyle yetişmek istemedim böyle ne
istediğini bilen biri karakter olmak
istemedim Ya da hani çevre Koç
Bu aile koşulları buna çok izin vermedi
Doğuş ile hep böyle hayatımda
istemediklerimi bulup onları hayatından
çıkar a bildikçe istediğimi buldum ve
yolunu öyle buldum işte o kurumsal
hayattaki çekingen ve çekim serbest toz
spor salonunda böyle aynanın karşısında
güçlü ve enerjik bir hal aldı Sonuçta
belli eski sporcu Yudum ve Jerry
kabiliyetim vardı yetenekliydi bir bilgi
birikimim vardı ve bu alanda daha fazla
öğrenme isteyin
bu Özgüven de ortaya çıkıp Yani bu
alandaki en öğrenme isteyin özgüvenim
ortaya çıkardı ve bu alanda bir şeyler
yapmaya karar verdim O aynı karşısında
gördüm işte Mutlu heyecanlı enerjik
besol şimdi yapmam gerekiyordu bende o
seçimi yaptım maddiyattan yani
kullanmadım yine bir anlamda list Siz
hayatı seçmedim ve böyle 6-7 senelik
işte kurumsal ve Ajans iş hayatı sonunda
32 yaşında başka bir sektörü fitness
spor sektörüne kaydım bizimkilere Bir
buçuk sene falan söylemedim herhalde iş
değiştirdim sektör değiştirdiğimi böyle
birlikte değil işte paralarla onları
eğitime yatırdığı hiç söylemedim zaten
az buçuk böyle İstanbul'da geçirmeye
çalışıyorsun Eşim Can O zamanlar Erkek
arkadaşım da onun Annem maddi ve manevi
desteği ol
bu işe alır mıydın Her şeyi sil baştan
başlar mıydı moda Aslında ayrı soru
işareti ama ne istemediğini bildiğim
yolda o verdiği destek benim için çok
değer verdim emin adımlarla gerçekten
Sabahat ederek sabırlı olarak
ilerlememiz sağladığı ilerledim
burasında bir aydınlanma Hani onu da
bizim isterim Her şeyi böyle kendim
yaparım işte benim kimseye ihtiyacım yok
anlayışı ben çok gerçekçi değilim çok
yorucu hocam böyle elinizi destek varsa
Çevrenizde sizi destek olan var herhangi
bir konuda hiç ona almaktan
değerlendirmekten çekinmeyin bir diğer
aydınlanma mdu4 LNB V aydınlanma değilim
Herhangi bir şey de başarıya ulaşmak
beklenildiği kadar kadar kolay olmuyor
bu aslında evrensel bir doğru Sizin de
bildiğiniz varsa yorum Siz de eminim
öyle düşünüyorsunuz dur
de böyle sektöre girdikten sonra işte
spor sektörüne fitness sektörüne
girdikten sonra her şeyi dört olur
sarıldım karşıma çıkan ne bulduysam
yaptım hiç o fırsatları değerlendirirken
iyi kötü işte İyi olur kötü olur diye
değerlendirme dim her şeyi değerlendirip
ayrıştırmadan kullanmaya çalıştım
eğitimler aldım mesela eğitimler
hakikaten Yurtiçi yurtdışı bu alandaki
eğitimleri aldım bunlar çok pahalıydı
onun yolunu o eğitim şirketinde
çalışarak buldum mesela eğitim
şeklindeki Hem o insanlarla bir arada
olacağım hem de bu isimleri ücretsiz
olacaktım şu spor salonlarında çalıştım
sporcu kimliğini ön plana çıkardı bunda
bir yer yapmaya çalıştım işte koştuğum
yüzdüm ayrı Ben yarışlarına katıldım ve
küstüğü görebilmek için biraz da böyle
adın duyulsun diye O da benim için bir
Çünkü fırsattı en çok antrenman yak
bu ve bu süre içerisinde de kurşu
aslında en basit en ucuz ve her zaman
her yerde yapabileceğini koşmak benim
hobim oldu mutfakta Çok keyif alıyorum
ve şekil Hani performaz göstermek
yanında koşmanın Kendisi de kurşununda
bir dünyada bir kültür olduğunu ve bu
kültürü Burada kendi ülkemize yay mam
gerektiğini Çünkü Bendeki pozitif
duygularımı duyguları insanların da
yaşaması gerektiğini hissettim ya da
farkına vardım 2012 yılında belki
bilmiyorum duymuşsunuzdur artık çok
aktif değil ama bu kızlar nereye koşuyor
diye ben ve böyle olsun işte çalışma
arkadaşı evrendeki yakın arkadaşlarımla
o kızlar nereye koşuyor değil hoşça
grubu kurduk ozamanlar hala böyle
Türkiye'nin ilk ve tek kış kuş kadın
koşu Kulübü amacımız da böyle bir seni
Evet birlikte koşuyoruz birlikte çok
keyif alıyoruz işte yarışlara gidiyoruz
Ben Osman'ı Kendisi de çok keyifli bir
spor Olduğunda biz bunu niye kendimizi
çevremizdeki kadınlara açılamıyorsun
değil daha fazla kadının hareket
etmesini sağlıyoruz amacıyla ortaya
çıktı İlk başta Aslında böyle kendi
çıkması daha çok biz beraber olalım diye
oluştuğu sonra bir sosyal sorumluluk
projesine dönüştü sonra özellikle benim
için diğerleri kızların farklı çünkü
hayatlarında amaçları ve görevleri vardı
ben onu kendime bir Bu da kendime bir
kariyer olarak görerek bunu Çevrendeki
insanları daha fazla yaymaya başladım
işte u mutluluğu o keyfi paylaştıkça
bundan kazanç sağlamaya başladığını İşim
oldu o dönemde işte Nike açalım hayatıma
like çıktı hemen akla çalışmaya başladım
Şu anda Türkiye'de iki tane koşu
alanında Nike running hoş var beni hem
fitness Nike fitness eğitmeni imar
Serpil indiriyor ama bir yandan da koşup
koşuyor
bu hamileliğimde de koştu konuşmak benim
için çok önemli belki görüyorsunuz
paylaşımlarında da her daim işte Hem
hayatımda koşturuyorum hayatım hep
koşarak geçiyor hem kendimden koşuyorum
hamileliğinde koştum 35 kilo Hasan'la
konuştum çocuğun doğru kızım Simdi oldu
kızım silmede koşmaya devam etti Çünkü o
hayatında hem aslında bana bir şekilde
kazanç sağlayan ve hayatıma pozitif
Yönet çeviren koşmayı kızın için
doğduktan sonra bırakmadım ne yapacağım
onu kendi hayatımı atak dedim İşte ona
uygun bir tane puset aldım Birlikte
koşmaya başladık kilometreler Koç yarı
maraton 21 kilometreler koştuk Şimdi
öyle bir koşu yarışı ne olduğunu çok iyi
bilir işte başına sert Finish olduğuna
sonunda Finch değişti musun verildiğini
şey oooo da böyle o Alkışlar Yeri geldi
uyuz yeri gelirse ben ona koşarak
hikayeler anlattım çok uzatmayayım
onlarda hoş MB Daha doğrusu bu sesle
konuşmaya devam ettik artık büyüdüm
ve sonra onu da kendi spor hayatını ve
kariyerini bir şekilde dahil ettiğim
için iki Eğitmen olarak aslında şu an
onunla beraber hem çocuklara hem de
büyüklere ders Biliyoruz şimdi böyle bir
squat nasıl yapılır bir bölge nasıl
yapılır birçok insandan çok daha iyi
biliyorum sadece beş yaşında öyle düşün
Eğer
Tamam canım söyleyeyim Belki biraz hızlı
gidiyorum ama spor sektöründe Ben 12
yılımı tamamladım Bu sürece gelene kadar
fakat en macera Uyusun da çok sıkıntılar
çektim ama başta da söyledim eşimin
ailemin desteğiyle çabalayarak Sabahat
ederek 12'nci yılında baktığımda Evet
böyle İstediğim yere ulaştın mı Oba
Şurayı yani o başarılı mıyım artık anne
o istediği başarıyı yakaladın mı o
başarıyı Ne tamam yani tanı tamamlayıp
da şunu söyleyeyim o başarıyı ne
tamamlayamazsın olunca bana vermen çok
mümkün değil öyle düşünüyorum Ee Fakat
ne yaptım yani belki Birçok insana göre
başarılıyım belki kendimce dediğim gibi
Ulaşırız Ahmet olarak tanımı yapamadığım
için bu sorunun cevabı vermekte belki
hani çok kolay olmayacak ama bu doğru
varsa yıl
ki sihir olarak böyle istemediklerimi
hayatından çıkararak iyi yapabildiğim ve
fayda sağlayabileceğim inancıyla
çıktığım bu yolda yeni Kariyer planlama
Aslında özgüvenle ilerliyorum ha bu beni
tatmin ediyor mu gerçekten Evet ediyor
hem işim yaparak Hem o benim yaparak bir
şekilde de bundan hayatımı işte Buralara
gelip arada tatil yaparak kendince çok
şeyden eksik kalmadan hayatıma
sürebiliyorum Evet inişler çıkışlar hep
var bence olmalıdır hayatta da ama bunu
hep böyle söylüyorum hayattaki en büyük
lüksüm gerçekten severek yaptığım daha
fazlasını öğrenmekten hiç kaçırmadım
daha fazlasını öğrenme heyecanı
içerisinde hep olduğum ve paylaşma bunu
paylaşma heyecanı içerisine olduğum en
önemlisi de belki işte huzurla
ve Her yeni güne merhaba dediğimi işim
var benim böyle hayatımdaki en büyük
lüksüm gerçekten daha büyük birlikte bir
katı bir yapı olması bilmiyorum büyüklük
mü Benim için değil ama her güne güzel
böyle huzurlu bir şekilde başlıyor olmak
yüzde sekseni hayatının işte geçiyorsun
işte benim gençlikten sonrasında gençlik
Sonrasında da önemli değil düşünüyorum
ev bu yönü var Erken işte yaşadığım
aydınlanma lar size neler değişti 4-5
tane aydınlanmadan basit çektim şu an
beni Sizin buraya işte önünüzde
konuşmaya aslında buraya kadar getirdi
Eğer bu
bu verilen tavsiyeleri bilmiyorum çocuk
örgü inanmayan biri olsaydım
Evet Ee bu duruma gelir miydim Sizin
karşınızda konuşurmuydu bilmiyorum ama
herhalde körü körüne İşte bu tavsiyeleri
inanmayan biri olarak Sanırım size
vereceğim en önemli tavsiye e Size
verilen tavsiyelere körü körüne
inanmayın olacak Buradan çıkıp edeceğiz
yani en önemli sonuç Bence bu bu Ne
istediğinizi bilen biri olmak Şahane Ama
ben öyle biri olmadı Dediğim gibi belki
olmak istemedim Ama merak etmeyin Ne
istediğinizi de zamanı anlayacaksınız
belki işte Ne istemediklerimizi hayattan
benim gibi hayattan çıkararak
anlayacaksınız bu Bazen kolay olacak
bazen zor olacak ama emin olun sadece
siz yaparsanız Bu mümkün sadece siz
yaparsanız bu olacak Dolayısıyla
güveninizi beş değil bol okuyun Google
seyahat edin ve bunların hepsini böylesi
indirdiğiniz zaman da kendi
ve güvenli hissettiğiniz zamanda da
bunları bıt paylaşın başkalarıyla
paylaşın Evet beni böyle biraz hızlı
hızlı oldu ama ha kadar Söyleyeceklerim
bu kadar böyle dediğim gibi çok dalgalı
bir denize yolunu bulmaya çalışan
çocukluğu gençliği belki yine bir aslan
burcu olarak box zorluklarla geçer ama
mücadele etmeyi Seçen hayatına risk
almayı Seçen Şu anda da böyle mutlu
huzurlu 15 olarak görün istiyorum
söylediğim tavsiyeleri de aydınlatmaları
olmuyorum Siz de hayatınızda yaşarsınız
ben çok uzatmayayım böyle tatlı bir
ortamdan tatlı bir konuşma olsun umarım
Bunlar da bu söylediklerinden bir
çıkarım çıkarırsınız sorularınız varsada
alırım sizden